abone ol
[Müzik]
Herkese
merhaba herkese ben Tıp Fakültesi
öğrencisiyim buradan kaplamalı
bilgilerle size sesleneceğim ama bundan
daha çok gurur duyduğum bir şey var bu
hayatımda Ben kanseri Yandım
Teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]
şöyle Bizim tıp fakültesinde bize ilk
öğretilen ve çok değerli olduğu da
bastırılan bilgi vardır sizinle
paylaşmak istediğim Biz aslında
hastalıkları iyileştirmiyor Uz Biz
hastalığı olan insanlara yerleştiriyoruz
ve ben size burada bir hastanın
kanserinden anlatacağım Benim
kaldırımdan tam alan ve kan kanserinin
birleştirme olmuş oluyor kıyafetlerine
başlıyor falan ve ağır kalkan zarar
Aslında Fakat ben yine de buradaysa bunu
anlatmaya değer buluyorum şöyle benim
hayatımda böyle kırılma nokta O çok
büyük tesadüfler var Ve bunlardan Sadece
üç tanesini size anlatacağım bugün
Bunlardan birincisi tek ile ilgili çok
ilginçtir ki ben daha önce dört kez
falan seyirci olarak katılmıştım zaten
hep kendim de düşünüyorum diyorum ki ben
o kırmızı halının üstüne çıksam ne
Anlatırım bir gün çıkabilir miyim acaba
buradayım Ve o zamanlar şunu düşünürüz
hani benim uzman olduğum bir konu yoktu
ya da üstüne çokça düşündüğüm ya da en
büyük tecrübelere sahip olduğu bir dal
yoktu ama artık var ve ben burada
bunları sizinle paylaşacağım şimdi
öncelikle bu tadex
tıbbi daha önce geldiğinde bir konuşma
vardı Ve bu konuşmada kan kanserlerinin
nasıl kök hücre nakli ile
çözülebileceğini neden kök hücre döner
olmamız gerektiğini anlatan bir konuşma
vardı ve ben bu konuşmadan çok
etkilenmiştim konuşmacı Aykut Bey ile
Daha sonrasında fotoğrafta çekilmiş tik
Daha sonrasında Tam beş ay sonra bu
fotoğraf çekiminden 15 Ice Ya ben kanka
test aldım tabii direkt elim telefona
gitti mesaj falan gönderdim dedim
Merhaba Aykut Bey beni Hatırladınız mı
böyle böyle ben sizin aranızda aydım o
zaman nasıl bir sağlıklıyım hiçbir şey
yoktu sonradan böyle bir şey çıkınca
başıma bir tık sallıyorsunuz sonra Bütün
ekip benim yanımda oldu Sağ olsunlar
gece gündüz her şeyde
yardımına koştular ihtiyacımı koydular
burada bir Afedersiniz burada biz Ben
hala hastanede yatarken Bu arada canlı
yayınlar yapıyorduk hatta bir ara kan
kök hücre ve organ bağışı üzerine günlük
bir rekor kırmak için Festival bile
düzenledik Bu benim için çok keyifliydi
hastalığını bir nebze olsun kenara koy
duruyordu bu tesadüflerden biriydi
İkincisi de benim testis aldığım gün o
çok ilginç bir tesadüf oluyor ama önce
teşhisten iki hafta öncesinde gidiyorum
o Ağustosun sonları Ben de yeni yeni
belirtileri bu hiçbirimizin hem de
hiçbirinizin ciddi alacağız belirtiler
değil En fazla yorgunluk oluyordu işte
belli kısa mesafelerde Normalde
yorulmadınız gereken bir mesafede
yoruluyorum dedim anlamışımdır nefes
darlığı gibi bir şey vardı dedim ailem
de astım var ondandır hep böyle
bahaneler buluyorsunuz daha sonra şans
eseri Ben doktora gittim göz
hastalıklarını ve şans eseri göz
kafesinde devasa bir kitle olduğunu
öğrendim 12/8 santim yani baktığımız
zaman Aslında büyük olduğu anlaşılıyor
Ve ben bunu Ne olduğunu anlamadım Tabi
sordum dediler bilmiyoruz Ameliyat olman
gerekebilir bunun için önce patolojiye
şey göndereceğiz örnek göndereceğiz
Tamam dedim gönderelim ama ben hemen
kendi duramadım tabi kendi üniversitemde
ki Fakültesi'ndeki kendi Göz göre hocam
aradım Dedim ki hocam böyle böyle Bana
diyorlar ki sana ameliyat olabilir misin
ona dedim ben size Muayene olmadan uçak
altına yapmak istemiyorum tabii dedi gel
muayeneye dedim Zannedersem sana
atacağım aynı O benim durumum ciddi
olduğunun farkına varmış Ben tabi
farkında değilim Benimle kardiyolojiden
hematolojiye her yere geldi bir güne
matematik kafasında yız ben tabi
zannediyorum ki işte kan sonuçlarıma 35
oynama var Bununla ilgili geldik Kapıda
bekliyoruz Hocaya dedim ki ya hocam İşte
ailem arkadaşlarım herkesi devam tuttu
yani ben anlamıyorum Altı üstü bir
ameliyat değil mi olup çıkacağım zaten
okulun açılmasına var Bir ay Hani
kankama Sana iki ayda iyileşirim Tamam
gelirim yani Ben bunu düşünüyorum hocam
bana söyle suratıma baktı ve dediği şey
benim için çok büyük bir hayat tarz oldu
dedi ki Azra cım Sen neyle karşı karşıya
kaldığının farkında değilsin O yüzden
anlamıyorsun Güzel kızım dedi bana Ben
içimden evet kesin öyledir dedim
Öyleymiş o anda bile hala anlamıyorum
çünkü yani evet bir kanseri deyince
toplumda baktığınız zaman konser eşittir
ölüm olarak görünüyor ama benim gözümde
Hani 3 beslerim alırım işte Saçlarım
dökülüyor Neyse çok önemli değil işte o
10'dan sonra ne olur işte midem bulanır
rengim Atar falan ama kalkar Maya gibi
düşünüyorum Merhaba siz peynir gelmiştim
yani bundan Sonrasında da işte
kitabından örnek aldılar hata size önüne
getirdim buraya bu dedim Cümbür Azra
herkes bebeğin icin biraz daha dar Bu
benim kitlem kanseri kür ederim artık
öldüler
beri işte örnek aldılar biyopsi için
gönderdiler Patoloji laboratuvarına aynı
zamanda Göğüs kafesinde 2 litre sıvı
birikmişti bunu çıkarmış olduğunu ve
baya bir nefes konusunda rahatlamış
oldum Daha sonra bize işte sonucu
beklemek için eve taburcu ettiler Tamam
dedim gidelim biz bekliyoruz ama iki
hafta sürebilirsin Heyecanlı bir
bekleyiş var İki tane ihtimal var
karşımda bir seçim onu biz bunun Tunus
bezinden kaynaklanan bütündür diyoruz
diğeri de ben falan kanseri İkisi de iç
açıcı bir sonuç değil ikisini ayırt
etmesini kimseye demez Yani benim gibi
birisi olduğum için edemez bizde
ne diyordu sadece dediğim gibi bugün
günlerden 15 Eylül 2019 hiç unutmuyorum
şimdi tesadüf Burada giriyor şimdi içine
bugün uyandım hepimiz gibi belki de
Instagram'da sorularda geziyorum Sabah
sabah bizim Okulumuzun bu eğitim
kollarından bir tanesi şey paylaşmış
bugün 15 Eylül dünya dan sonra
farkındalık günü işte lan sonuç şöyle
bir hastalıktır böyle bir kanserdir
şöyle gelişir böyle işte ölümcüldür ya
da değildir falan bu tarz bilgiler vardı
baktım ben dedim ki bu hafta benim
başıma gelir bu Dünya'da başkasına olmaz
tamam dedim Benim için teşhisinden sonra
öğlene doğru oldu olmadı beni hastaneden
aradılar dediler azrah Senin sonucu
çıktı gelip almam lazım bilen bilir
Patoloji sonucu çıktığı zaman size
telefondan öyle sonucu söylemezler Gelip
doktora görüşmemiz gerekir Biz de öyle
yaptıkları gittik hemen koşa koşa
hocayla da önce bir havadan sudan
konuşuyoruz sonra hocam bana Ya böyle
işte dedi sonucunu bilmek istiyor musun
hocam dedim Ben zaten biliyorum
cevaplayan falan kim söyledi dedi
nereden biliyorsun dedi çünkü söylemesi
gerekiyor adamların birisi söylemedi
sıkıntı yaratma Yalım ama böyle böyle
Bugün dünyanın en son farkındalık günü
bu dedim Olsa olsa bana olur Ben
biliyorum sonra hocam biraz Güldür Biraz
şey yaptı Tabii ortamda biraz hüzünlendi
Tahmin ettiğiniz üzere dedim Hocam
sıkıntı değil Şimdi ne yapacağız onu
söyleyin Hoca Tabi bir şaşırdı çünkü
hani ağlamak seni krizi ne bileyim
gülmek herhangi bir tepki vermemiştim
dıştan Tabi ben 2 tane tepkim olmadığını
zannediyordum ama varmış Tabii doğal
olarak Hepimiz insanız
Hocam çok sevindi bu çekim karşısında
dedi ki Tamam hadi hemen işte işlemlere
başlayalım salon hastaneye yatışı
gerçekleştirdik Ben orada sordum dedim
Kemoterapi ne kadar sürüyor hiçbir
şeyden haberim yok benim Ben Tıp
Fakültesi bir sene okumuşum hiçbir şey
bilmiyorum dedim ki masrafı ne kadar
sürüyor hoca dedi Senin ilacın beş gün
aradım tamam o bu açılmasını iki hafta
var ve beş gün ilaç olsa saçların falan
herhalde o hafta dökülür diye bişi yok
öyle değilmiş işte ilaçlar verilir
bulantı yapar şu olur bu olur Ben dedim
ki haftaya kalkarım Ameliyat falan da
yok ya sonuçta önce dedim ki hocam dedim
ben okula döneceğim Hani bir an önce
başlayalım ilacı Hoca dedin Halkalı
diyorsun sen ne diyorsun Hocam ne zaman
okula döneceğim yok dedi bir kür de
değil mi Bir gün bir gün dediniz yok
dedi O öyle değil geldi yanıma oturdu
bütün süreci anlattı işte kemoterapi
şöyle İşler bu yüzden yeni bir gün sürer
senin hiçbir şekilde değil hastaneden
odamdan çıkmam lazım hocam dedim Siz o
zaman ayaktan tedavi yapıp Geçmedi mi
sanki çok biliyorum ya profesörden sonra
Doktor Geldi Karşıma oturdum Koskoca
Profesör gelip bana laf anlatmaya
çalıştı dedi ki aza bak Bu öyle değil
bana bütün detayları anlattı Sen de
baktık öğrencisisin anlarsın ki
anlamadım
Hadi be Ondan sonra geldi Evet şunu da
söyle dedi ki bak bu süreç ucu olacak
haberin olsun Sevdim yani ne kadar zor
olabilir ki ben aynı hatayı fakültesini
tercih ederken de yapmıştım ne kadar zor
olabilir ki çok zormuş yapmayın bundan
sonrasında şöyle bir sıkıntı yaşadık
Hoca dedi ki ben hocam bana o zaman
şöyle bir süre söyleyin hani şu kadar ay
kesinlikle hastanedesin diyeyim ki ben
kendimi ona göre ayarlayayım Hani
hayatımda küçük kadar zamanı Ben kenar
alayım Hoca dedi ki altı ay boyunca
kesinlikle tedavide geçecek üstünü
bilemem Bir Yıldırım iki olur iki
Yıldırım bir yıl olur bu dedi Belli
olmaz tamam dedim ben istediğim cevabı
aldım sıkıntı yok aldım altı ayın önüme
koydum düşündüm dedim ki ben Azra Bulut
Ben kanser hastasıyım 20 yaşındayım o
zamanlar şu an yaşlandım 20 yaşındayım
ve benim altı ayım kesinlikle hastanede
geçecek plan yapmıyorum Ve ben hala
okula dönmeyi düşünüyorum sebebin
tekerlekli sandalyeli odama getiriyor
evet hadi küre Biliyorsun da niye
bilmiyorum ben şey demişti mesela Ya
anne ben yurda ne eşyalarını götüreceğim
şimdi Hoca bir yandan Gülsüm'e ağlasın
mı O da ayrı bir durum Sonra dedim ki
okulunu Bir yıl boyunca dolduracaksın
Dondurmam dedim yapmam böyle
dolduracaksın de dondurma dediler ki bir
kemoterapi al görüşürüz dedim size ben
Oradan bakınca bir kemoterapi ile
yıkılacak birine mi benziyorum Hoca dedi
ki sen al görüşürüz kemoterapinin 1.
günü başladık herşey herşey normal
gidiyor ben Turp gibiyim Hiçbir şey yok
Meltem abla gitmemişler daha tiroid
vermişler iki güne geçtik artık
kemoterapi ile tanıştım baktım böyle
duvara bakıyorum duvar kayıyorsa
bakıyorum sağ kayıyor hayatımda
yaşadığım en kötü onlardan biriydi Belki
de sonra dedim tamam getirin evrakları
ben vazgeçtim donduracağım bu okulum
Oğlum bu
Bunlardan başka olarak yine bir tesadüf
olarak bahsedeceğim ben en yakın
arkadaşımın Ne oldu Sadece arkadaşıma
değil tanıdıklarımı da buldum Şu anda
hala daha bir kere bir teyze vardı Ben o
zamanlar tabii odaya sığamıyorum şöyle
düşünün 12 metrekarelik 1 oda 20
yaşındasınız hayatımızın en hareketli
dönemleri ve size diyorlar ki bu odadan
çıkmayacağız şimdi bu mümkün değil
Burada bir anlaşalım ve Sizden bunu
istediklerinde haklı olduklarını da
biliyorsunuz çünkü sizin iyiliğiniz için
ama olmuyor Ben sürekli kaçma Yolları
arıyordum mesela yapmayın uygun bir şey
değil Sırma askısını alalım Scooter gibi
kayıyorum koridordan koridora çok canım
sıkılıyordu kafayı kulaklığın vardı
Böyle takıyorum onu hemşireler arkandan
bağırırken duymuyordu mesela sonra beni
alıp kedi yavrusu bir insandan tutup
ciddi ciddi ol Ama bırakıyorlardı geri
Bir keresinde şey yaptım hatırlıyorum
odaya kıyafet sipariş açmıştık bir
elbiseydi elbise geldi ben hemen
deneyeceğim Çünkü kolumdaki serum
çıkarttırdım elbiseyi denemek için
elbise giydim geri taktılar mesela çok
inatçıyım o konuda Onun dışında şöyle
bir şey oluyor Ben zaten hani bunu bir
yere kadar geçiyor geçiyor ama
sıkıyorsunuz ne yapacağım ben bir ona
maket yaptım birden örgüye başladım
Hatta öğrendiğimde ölmeyi de ters düz
falan Sonra toza alerjim çıktı ortaya
çıktı Ondan sonra o da artık geride
kaldı ne yapacaksın dizi film bir yere
kadar gidiyor hep bitmiyor Ama şöyle bir
şansım var dedi kim konusunda bizim
sakal denen uygulama yapılıyor çok
detaya girmeyeceğim bedeninizden bir
iğne ile beni sinir sistemi kurmak için
yapılıyor bu işlemden sonra dört saat
gündüz yapmak zorundasınız yastık yok
ayağa kalkmak yok Tuvalete bile gitmek
yok Sadece su içmek için başınızı
kaldırabilirsiniz ama gerek yatacaksınız
böyle bir tane dört saat uyumuyor Yani
günün ortası olunca
ben de şey yapmıştım Yemek masasında
bilirsiniz hastane odalarında ki en
yüksek seviyesine kaldırıyorsunuz onu
yatağa da en aşağıya kadar
indiriyorsunuz aynı C şeklinde ya yatağa
doğru giriş yapıyor Sanki yemek yemeye
hazırlanıyor musunuz gibi altına Ben
bantlarla şehir yeni başlamıştım oradan
dedi filmi izliyorum artık başka türlü
bir sonuç olmak zorundasınız
sıkıyorsunuz Çünkü Es almıyorsunuz ya
bedeni Nasılsa kaç yazar ruhunu
sıraladıktan Sonra
işte bu Teyze'ye döneceğim zaman ben
yine aynı kulaklığım askılık oğlum da
kemoterapi cihazı falan var Senin
baskısıdır bankaya gidiyorum girdim
odaya baktım teyze Böyle yazmış 50'li
yaşlar dış şey demişti Ben de mi ateşte
kadın ne yapıyorsun Yap dediler
yatıyorum kızım dedi
dedim teyze yani öyle olmazmış kat dedim
Oturmaya mı geldik hadi Ondan sonra
teyze bana baktı böyle Sonra bir şey
demedi sonra annemle falan Konuşmaya
başladılar Ben sıkıldım çıktım odadan
sonra da ararım uğramıştım vardır bırak
aradan aylar geçti biz bu teyze ile aynı
hafta Kök hücre nakli olduk Aynı hasta
taburcu olduk aynı hafta güzel haberler
aldık tabi kök hücre naklinden sonra her
hafta bir şekilde kontrole gitmek
zorundasınız kontrole gidiyorum Teyze'ye
görüyorum rastlıyoruz falan bugün bu
odadaki Abi bak sana bir şey diyeceğim
sana abla dedim buyur bak dedi ben dedi
ne ilaçlar Ne Doktorlar Ne işte
kemoterapi Radyoterapi hiçbir şey dedi
kurtarmadı Sen kurtardın Estağfurullah
abla dedim Ne demek istiyorsun bana dedi
ki o da mı geldiğin ilk günü hatırlıyor
musun sen 20 yaşındaydın hayatının
baharında Aydın Ben 50 küsür eşinden
zaten yaşamışım yaşayacağım kadar ben bu
saatten sonra kaybedecek bir şeyim yok
oturmuşum ya Ölürsem de kendim kendi
içmiyorum ama sen hayat doluydu Neşe
doluydu bana güç katlı şimdi içeride kan
sonuçlarımı bekliyorum Ama eminim ki
tertemiz çıkacak Çünkü senin sayende
demişti bu beni çok etkilemişti ben
bundan sonra zaten ne yapacaksam elimden
ne geliyorsa daha fazlasını yapmaya
karar verdim gün buydu
teyzeden başka dediğim gibi en yakın
arkadaşımla tanışmış oldum ben sahnede
çok güzel bir hikaye bir döneminde kök
hücre naklinden önce benim yaşadığım
ilçede benim adımı bir kampanya gibi
birşey başladılar Biz Azrail ve diğer
hastalar için diye herkes kök hücre
veriyor böyle Bankası bekler gibi herkes
kök hücre sırası bekliyor Çok
etkileyiciydi zaten yüksek olan yaşama
motivasyonumu daha duygusu atmıştı Ben
zaten yaşamayı aşık bir insanım ben çok
seviyorum hayatta kalmayı
ondan sonra bana bir mesaj geldi yine
yaşadığım ilçeden bir kız yazmıştı bunu
dediğine göre işte senin yaptığın
hastanede senin yaptığın serviste tam
altı ay önce ben oradaydım ve ben
kanseri yendim Sıra sende eğer bir sorun
sıkıntı olursa bana yazabilirsin mesaj
atabilirsin istersen ziyaretine gelirim
fazla güzel bebeklerde bulunmuştu çok
etkilendim Tabi ki neden olmasın Ben de
isterim yolundan geçmiş birisini tanımak
o şekilde ziyaretime geldi kafalarımız
Çok güzel uçtu arkadaş olduk zamanla Ben
taburcu oldum ondan sonra beraber hepsi
kontrol lerimize gidip geldi çok
mutluyuz dışarıda buluşabiliriz artık
enfeksiyon sorunun atmışım Ondan sonra
aradan biraz zaman geçti mi mi Evet iki
sene önce bugün yani yine benim doğum
günümdü mü hala bana bir mesaj attı
dediğim gibi en yakın arkadaşım ve ben
hayatımda Dona kalmayı tırnaklarımın
ucuna kadar hissettim bana dediği şey şu
anda benim karnım çok ağrıyor beni
hastaneye kaldırdılar Galiba nüksetti
dedim Yok ya neden Üşütmüşsün Dürüm
olacak ki
yok dedi Öyle değil galiba bu sefer
yalnız olur falan kan sonuçları geldi
hemen hastaneye yatırdılar yüksekmiş
dedim tamam sıkıntı yok bir kere yendik
daha yeneriz Öyle değil mi aynı olan bir
daha geçeceğiz Evet doğru ama ben senin
yanındayım nasıl ki sen benim yanımdaydı
böyle oldu ben hep ziyarete gittim orada
Hazal dışında iki tane daha akranla
tanışma şansı yakaladım İkisi de Adaş da
hatta Enes isimleri arkadaşlarımızla Biz
Aşağı Kur'an yaşlarda öyle düşün ve
hepimiz artık aynı şeylerden unutmuşuz
aynı şeylerden bunu almışız çok
sıkılıyoruz ve aynı zamanda bir hasta bu
projemiz var ziyarete gelenleri Hani
kibar davranmıyoruz kayda söyleyeyim ama
biz birbirimizi anlıyoruz sonra bize şey
geldi Diğer arkadaşımız hastaneye geldi
dört kişi de dört kişiyiz 3 hastanede
yatıyor ben ta burcuyum işte ben de
nakil olacağım o dönemde sana derken
daha da yattı onlar orada buluştu Ben
her zaman Kontrole gittiğim zaman onları
ziyaret ediyorum bir hatta bir hayalini
kurduk bir gün söyledi biz bir şekilde
karavan bulacaktık tatlı kafaya dedi ki
Ege sahillerini gezeceğiz çok güzel bir
planda ama hepimizin iyileşmiş olması
gerekiyor Bunun için ben hepimizin
enfeksiyon gibi sıkıntıları atlatmış
olması gerekiyor Tamam dedik yaparız o
gün de gelir bekleriz sonra hasta
taburcu oldu bir dönem Ben ziyaretine
gittim Dedim ki
sen nasılsın falan İyiyim dedim enesler
nasıl en aza dedi Haberin Yok Mu
ne dedim ne neyden haberim yok mu Hadi
Deniz kaybettik Hayır dedim ya ben Geçen
hafta telefonla konuştum Hani mümkün
değil yok dedi kaybettik arkasında
kontrolüm vardı çok yatıyorum ben
servisi uçarak gittim Dedim ki ben
Enes'in odasına gireceğim hemşireler
durumu biliyor yok Azra Yapma etme
arkadan Doktor gelmişti bırakın Görsün
de haklısın ben odaya bir girdim iki
tane kadın gördüm genç olan yerdeki
valizden eşyaları alıp dolaba kuasi
yordu dedim Evet onlar yeni gelmiş
Pardon deyip çıktım ama sesini Ben de
duymadım Yani sonra ben seni krizine mi
Ağlama krizine girmişim son birkaç saat
hatırlamıyorum sonra eve geldim falan
filan aradan iki hafta geçti diğeriniz
kaybettik ya Ne oluyor falan derken Hadi
bana dedi ki Merak etme ben seni yalnız
bırakmayacağım Ben şu an çalışıyorum ama
devam edeceğim Çünkü bizim adımıza
üstünde kanser Savaşçısı ama dedi bana
bir Ama sen de beni bırakmayacaksın
Tamam dedim söz hiç problem değil
ondan sonra öyle birbirimize bu şekilde
anlaşmalarımız var bir hala devam
ediyoruz görüşmeyi ara enesler iade
diyoruz falan ve ben şu an bu sahnede
Hazal'ın Öldüğü Yaştayım Bugün benim
doğum günüm ve ben doğum günlerini aşık
bir insan olarak hiç bu kadar hüzünlü
geçeceğini düşünmemiştim
da size demek istediğim şey Hayat çok
kısa Hadi alayım Hiç yaşındaydı çok kısa
ve size benim bu tecrübelerimden
hayatımdan Anladım Dört şeyi aktarmak
istiyorum birincisi
karşı karşıya olduğunuz durumun farkında
olmayabilirsiniz Kendinize iyi davranın
ikincisi
tesadüfleri kabullenin Çünkü kabullenme
den geçmiyor ben kabullendim Altı ayı
öyle rahat ettim üçüncüsü Umut saçın hiç
ölmeyecekmiş sesini umutlu olun dördüncü
ve sonuncusu ise Kimin ne zaman
gideceğini bilmiyoruz
Yarın geleceklermiş gibi sevinirim
etrafınızdakileri hepinize sağlıklı
günler diliyorum